a new chapter for the Raja Park says
Gautama Rajapaksa brother of a former
president and himself an ex defense
secretary
now the candidate for the Sri Lanka pada
juniperus Munna party for elections
expected later this year I love my
country I'm proud of my country and I
have a vision for the future of this
country I value this opportunity to give
leadership to all Sri Lankans and bring
peace happiness and prosperity to the
motherland
Gautama Rajapaksa led the military to
victory over the Tamil Tigers ending 26
years of civil war he was given a free
hand by his brother then President
Mahinda Rajapaksa to do so but
accusations of human rights abuses and
war crimes plagued his tenure many
Tamils in the north and east are still
looking for answers about their missing
relatives or those abducted under Raja
Parks's watch some complain of
intimidation and harassment when they
tried to speak up Sharon Saviour who has
worked with these communities says his
candidacy for president is causing
concern he's seen as a terminator on
dissent yes so in that contact like an
old people are a bit worried about I
mean in any kind of dissent will not be
tolerated so this this space maybe there
were like you know a little bit of space
for not just alone the civil society
members but as public in general in the
north and east or like areas where the
numerical minority is a living so in
that context that space whether that is
going to shrink Rajapaksa seems to be
aware of such concerns telling the party
convention on sunday that the diversity
of communities in sri lanka
is its strength it's taken one term for
Sri Lankans who voted a Rajapaksa
president out of office to look at his
brother as a potential leader the reason
according to one political commentator
lies with the current government which
has not fulfilled people's expectations
the failure of the democratic experiment
has opened up space new political space
for and the counter Democratic
authoritarian alternative so whatever
our personal personifies you know that
you know political space which has been
opened up in Sri Lankan society the new
candidate gave supporters some insights
into his views on the country's
sovereignity security and the
environment presidential elections must
be held by December 8th those
campaigning for gota BAE Rajapaksa say
he's a terminator and will stamp out
corruption and fraud but won't be an
authoritarian leader that something Sri
Lankan voters will have to decide
whether to believe or not when they
choose their next president Meena
Fernandez al Jazeera Colombo